haha my name get it there we go
that your god it's an effect do you
really mean it no I didn't mean that
anyway
a lot of girls here tonight stop girls
are you then
I don't mind me just moving you aside
because I want to enter your vajayjay I
guess technically this is as much as I
don't want it to be I can't help that
[ __ ] come on Jennifer but I know you do
but we can't stay together but why
you're a stoner but I can change no you
don't be late come on let me just
squeeze your too bad Jennifer come on
give me kiss okay I know Jennifer got
the boys of that well [ __ ] me come on I
love to not you Jenner come on you fatty
goddamn you're fat there we go there we
go look at that I own
Miami tail you got that's nice
possession
look at that penis it's like oh yeah
take me I can't move thank you hey kind
of saw that coming but it still scares
the [ __ ] out of me
all right here we go give me that [ __ ]
oh girl look at that body girl look at
that body oh he works out I like his
little wiener it's like why can't they
just have [ __ ] closing this Oh what
the hell is that what are you some kind
of saucer
ah that makes sense I mean that's a part
of a sit here in this little hole here
makes total sense if you think about it
I mean I've been in a lot of places with
no I actually haven't been sorry sorry
it's my way there we go not a problem
not to press up Jennifer I'm sorry don't
care series a relax don't do it when you
wanna go through it it relax don't do
it's downstairs I remember there's a pot
of acid here let's go up sup how you
doing my where is he oh there you are
you little penis [ __ ]
alright I got an idea super bad idea
actually
that's not the way I planned all right
here we go come on hi big penis guy I
mean small penis fine AHA I offend it
hello
come back come in come here all right
step it out hey I [ __ ] your mama last
night oh that's right I did it
and you liked it all right you're
supposed to go here this is stupid [ __ ]
right oh that's right no come here
around the corner you're stupid every
guy that I would go that but God never
got a thing with it it's coming it's
coming it's coming
Oh stubborn [ __ ] I go there yay the
thought but I got dying planet don't you
ever say your [ __ ] this mom I'm sorry
but it had to be done why am I here oh
[ __ ] me this better work nah [ __ ] I'm so
screwed something right place there we
go there we go hurry the [ __ ] up please
hurry the [ __ ] up please oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] open please no me
gusta no me [ __ ] oh oh thank God thank
God thank God
all right it's going here I feel like
this are [ __ ] me I need a Keena
god damn you needed a lot of [ __ ] for
that door Halas snoop around the Shiva
River no son
but that's not what's important that's
important is lessons will
knife about how we have whatever
goddamnit have to go down here I warned
you about this bro
god dammit James happening ah [ __ ] me
alright it's okay I can just do my
nipple twist I love it
left right nipple right nipple left
nipple right name there we go I warned
you about the Stars bra goddamn stairs
man what is this before it comes back a
side to side my brother too
he's hunting some right now Stan okay
stone cold name bruh
god damn you're generous with these I
feel like you're are you Ellen side you
Ellen Ellen do you love me Wow what are
you doing with these people and I
supposed to communicate a damn [ __ ]
barrels all right I guess I can make it
cozy and [ __ ] yeah but gah
god yes oh yeah all right oh oh yay
very good very good it's locked all of
this [ __ ] is locked I don't I don't know
why oh this is a prison I'm so stupid so
stupid I feel so embarrassed right now
alright that stopped let's make it nice
and cozy in here
no monsters we'll see ah this one works
cool hi hi nice but what are you doing
staring at his butt Hey hi Perry
that's some more lamb no tail
sorry what oh you got another I knew you
were a bro Melky may know T or whatever
you name it give that [ __ ] I can't grab
it
come on come on baby come on don't [ __ ]
with me right now whatever I got Wow
Wally Wow shut up
now I like what's going on in here
watched Wow shut up goddamn it
go eat the poo here you go well he only
got a hat there we go yeah you look cool
nice swag Wally better not touch that
that's not I got oh no [ __ ] oh nice flip
I mean not nice black Palliser's
potatoes hey don't follow me
that's right that's right oh the bridge
why don't mother sever uses I never see
them it's awesome this place was really
terrifying it's just that it happened so
late in the game son Oh No oh hell no I
just picked up the dagger stabbed people
with I guess I gotta kill someone
that's how about route with yeah that's
how oh that's me what are you doing I
thought I don't know I just happened to
be in the neighborhood you know I was at
my I don't even know all right this way
payday you have to go this way okay
let's go later then right now never here
I think let me check sure whenever
you're ready don't question me all right
it wasn't here got back where am I
suppose is this cutting and skinning I
didn't really see anything oh no oh hell
no
now my guest she coming or what Wow
take it easy payday he might be just
around the corner all right cool yes it
was us I'll distract him for you hey hey
what's up come here don't do that to
father you're crazy I know in a crazy
man god damn you
may I maybe I'm supposed to kill him I
don't know oh [ __ ] he sees me okay he
doesn't wait where did he go seongjun
one second ago I'd you stupid [ __ ]
he's blind anyway so that made no sense
alright let's go I'm sure you open the
door or something oh maybe this one okay
let's go over here that it's with the
floor here I suspect something going on
the final I'll just leave you here cuz I
need need to find whatever [ __ ] I'm
doing
oh alright that way cool yeah like a
boss pity I'm break that's it for you
yeah it's very ah of course they are
here I'll guard them by standing on them
I guess that makes sense
let me just grab this battle you can
just not want to cause any trouble today
bow just passing by oh hell no I'll
check if it's safe really yeah cuz
you've done such a good job yeah their
time is it safe I'm not shy be careful
pity thank you woah oh no no
No Oh No well that's a huge ascii I
[Music]
don't like they finally come in with me
I don't want to be on [ __ ] clothes
the [ __ ] all right here we go there we
go so comfortable sup spikes and then
nice weather today isn't it
I don't want that oh [ __ ] me
that ass a sweet ass
[Music]
alright an unmarked key that was a
couple other doors locked I guess
goddamn I hate him probably most of all
of them Hana what are you doing this
guy's bday that was a wild ride
alright so anything in these spin the
wheel I'm spinning brand new rule I'm
rich spinning
Jesus Christ goddamn calm down all right
I'll see you later you [ __ ] I
guess it's this one I would make sense
at least
alright let's ease the key over here god
damn it I come on ah calm down your
pants pity you have to make a fire
otherwise you're doing that surprised
you're still alive
me too actually sup sup alright let's go
there was one door I think yeah this one
all right you wait here spanner and I'll
shake detect
oh hell no the hell happened here brah
brah what did they do they yeah Robbie
they I'd scratch that Thank You payday
thank you uh you're welcome well if
you're reading this you're probably dead
if you see my body there then yes
now run I can be anyway with that mean
whatnot and what things got a brofist
today but hey that's cool bro bro okay
I'm pretty confident that whoever made
this ran the Ripper all right yeah all
right I'm doing it but oh maybe used to
saw buddy so let's saw him no maybes
dick he doesn't have one really son but
there's gotta be something all right
where [ __ ] so loud
why are we going ah [ __ ] me this is
round if I hate it I know it [ __ ]
nerd ah [ __ ] you came from there
well my brother on that I think I have
to
ah [ __ ] god damn it
this guy's pissing ah okay of course
great let's do like this defined huh
Vinnie listen carefully oh stop I had a
nice finish let's go ah that's an odd
way
let's go carry my god dammit
there be I suck I'm sorry it says I
think we need to go in that door woody
came from so I'm sorry I suck I don't
like it's the fauna ah I'm sorry
I really suck today but that's ok gotta
learn things in life this is off ok got
a key
cool give me that [ __ ]
entrance door king well I will check all
the doors just make no sense no wait a
second wait a second maybe hey nice
breakdown skills maybe going back but we
really didn't get our training
let's check it everyone about the stairs
bro alright is this let's try it
maybe there's another door that's locked
ah I know yeah yeah
I don't oh [ __ ] I gotta end this outside
all right nice break then I guess I can
go over here and then then whoa whoa
well let's go nan-oh Jennifer what are
you doing I breakdance just for you
I know I know it's cool but the [ __ ]
all right brass I will end this episode
here and the next episode would go over
to this guy and see what he has in there
but don't tell that like vision yours
it's gotta come bread today and I'll see
you next that's for sure
[Music]
okay yeah yeah come on got Hey
[Music]
oh come to me man